aujourd'hui la majorité des députés sont
avocats cab fonctionnaires y at il des
ouvriers dans l'hémicycle
1945 la classe populaire est bien
présente à l'assemblée nationale
décidément je ne souhaite pas apporter
du nombre au total soixante cinq
ouvriers parmi 5 122 députés ça restera
un record mais rapidement les ouvriers
sont moins nombreux sur les bancs de
l'assemblée pourtant en 1967 la
représentativité sociale semble est
cruciale pour ce député je crois que le
fait d'avoir dans une assemblée des
personnes provenant d'activités de
professions différentes est extrêmement
important à la place des ouvriers des
fonctionnaires des cadres et autres
professions libérales s'installe à
l'assemblée de quoi questionné un
journaliste de l'humanité
vous pensez que les députés de votre
parti du dr
qui compte plus de choix sont
administrateurs de sociétés sont
représentatifs vraiment de la nation
dans la composition sociale la nation je
crois bien que c'est le peuple qui a élu
ses députés alors qu'ils aient pris un
directeur de société
l'ouvrier ou un fonctionnaire ça c'est
dans chacun rob hichens le choix des
électeurs
les élections s'enchaînent et la classe
populaire disparaît lentement de
l'assemblée même dans les années 80
alors que la gauche est au pouvoir la
chute du nombre d'ouvriers continue il
ya eu un temps de rêve du suffrage
universel la constitution démocratique
où on s'est dit on va faire de la
promotion de toutes les catégories au
sein des détenus par le monde bah il se
trouve qui a pratiquement pas
pratiquement pas d'ouvriers d'employés
c'est aussi un sacré problème les
raisons de ce changement le parti
communiste s'effondre un peu plus à
chaque législative et le ps
s'embourgeoise alors quand un ouvrier
fait son entrée à l'assemblée nationale
en 1997
ça devient un événement l'idée vient
surtout des gens avec qui je travaille
qui m'ont dit il faut que tu montres que
tu représentes le monde ouvrier et ça
serait bien pour la première saison suit
alors le travail en 2012 retour du parti
socialiste et un seul député ouvriers
sur 577
2017 sonne le glas plus aucun ouvrier
dans l'hémicycle c'est une première
depuis 1946 ces nouveaux élus et ce
qu'ils sont représentatifs j'allais dire
sociologiquement de la société française
alors oui et non c'est vrai qu'il y a
moins de fonctionnaires moins de
retraités qu'auparavant mais on est
quand même sur des catégories
socioprofessionnelles plutôt élevé il ya
du renouveau mais c'est toujours la
france diplômés la france aisés qui est
aux commandes 0 consent d'ouvriers à
l'assemblée nationale en 2017 alors
qu'ils représentent 20% des français en
revanche
76 % de cadres et de professions
intellectuelles alors qu'il représente
17,1 pour cent de la population
[Musique]